[Musique]
on
où
[Musique]
et ça y est on arrête la musique on y va
comme ça bonjour bonjour comment allez
vous aujourd'hui bienvenue dans ce
nouveau live alors je vous présente tout
de suite je suis avec jimmy jimmy temps
devant aux vendeurs fnac experts google
est ce qu'on peut dire ça comme ça
experte n'a qu' ambassadeur alcool
speaking micro in the micros micro donc
oui je suis expert fnac et également
l'ambassadeur chez google parce que vous
l'aurez compris aujourd'hui c'est un
live qui est réalisé en partenariat avec
la fnac mais également avec google pour
parler de quoi pour parler de ça ça
c'est quoi regardons les mais la paf on
les montre sont les pixels six pixels
six pros alors les pixels six pixels six
pros sont déjà sortis à quelques temps
mais je suis sûr que vous ne le savez
pas que ses smartphones vous apporte de
nouvelles fonctionnalités extrêmement
régulièrement et en fait il se réinvente
et ça qui est extrêmement intéressant
alors guy yes si tu me le permet avant
qu'on aille parler plus en détails de
ses smartphones et puis de relire vos
petits messages dans le chat parce que
regarder là j'ai mon ordi là on fait des
choses on est dégueu d'un an des d'alger
jurade un peu les messages et au
monsieur vocation de contrôler en a
partout hein c'est la tour de craindre
là on est à niveau ne va pas pleuvoir
normalement mais bon on va tout droit on
arrive normalement des protégés contre
la pluie tout devrait bien se passer
alors je vous le dis on est là pourquoi
40 45 minutes en fonction de deux vous
en fonction de nous en fonction de
tourner bien des bien installé il ya
plusieurs choses à savoir jimmy oui
plusieurs choses à savoir première chose
c'est smartphones sont toujours en vente
et ça c'est plutôt bien et alors je vous
le dis tout de suite parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ait le 25 mai ont dès
le 25 mai on est de 25 mais je confirme
on la pensait pas que c'est du direct
mais bien le 25 mai alors notre
carrément directeur on peut le montrer
sur les pixels et il est 18h30 et un
contrôle sur le peuple à regarder on
passe sur le plan du dessus sur laquelle
la caméra larretche à meyrals à mon ami
18h31 18h31 alors il se peut qu'ils
aient un tricheur calage parce que le
flux vous savez le temps qu'ils partent
d'ici qu'ils soient traités qu'il arrive
chez vous peut-être qu'on a quelques
petites bonnes secondes d'écart et que
des fois le 31 7 du 32
voilà on demande pardon à tout le monde
dessine on est là au regard des messages
importants parce qu'en fait on né le 25
comme je vous le disais mais doté ça
dans vos agendas si vous avez un peu
pied un petit papier vous le prenez
prenez un crayon prenez ce que vous
voulez doter le parce que du 27 hier
dans deux jours puisqu'on est le 25e wen
ont deux jours grosse surprise basse et
sa grosse surprise du 27 mai au 10 9
juin à la fnac sur le site de la fnac je
vous ai mis les liens dans le live là
vous avez les liens vous cliquez
regardez comme ils équipés c'est beau
brand des fnac on y est et bien vous
allez avoir 100 euros de remise pour
l'achat de vos smartphones pixels 6 ou
alors le pixel six pros et ça c'est
vachement bien donc attendez deux jours
je vous conseille quand même attendre
deux jours pour tes 200 euros de remise
parce que ses smartphones dans mes notes
quelque part ici alors le pixel 6 mon
ami montre le pixel si c'est le cas le
pixel 6 la ba 106 e le voici ça c'est la
boîte site une nouvelle en verre ça va
pas le faire le pixel sicile et à 649
euros c'est le tarif du pixel 6 et le
pixel syspro ylea attention tac on est
mieux qu'à hollywood 6 600
899 l'euro donc ça veut dire vous avez
touché de pixels 6 à 549 euros c'est
hyper canon et le pixel syspro à
899 euros donc ça c'est le premier truc
à savoir et le deuxième truc alors j'ai
vu que dans le chat vous étiez nombreux
à poser un peu des questions là-dessus
coucou le chat hello les beaux gosses ça
et tu vois tout le monde arrive c'est
sympa 18h30 et on voit effectivement on
se met à leur attention avec cette
chaleur un bon petit période y met au
jour mr par hayek est un copain qui est
là qui est aussi un youtube heures de
talent alors il ya concours je voulais
me hante optent en top commentaires en
top chat épinglés allez jeter un oeil
parce que en fait et ça c'est super
chouette vous envoyez un email vous
allez pouvoir gagner un pixel 6
attention se parle bien de celui là pour
gagner un pixel 6 on vous l'offre enfin
grosse pas moi mais c'est pas moi non
plus c'est pas moi non plus notamment vu
refaire les pompes fonctionnent et vous
il va être faire rire et vous allez à
gagner à pixel 6 et vous allez gagner
également ça tu peux montrer s'il te
plaît jimmy on y va on se met en quatre
ans les jumelles retour moniteur parce
que des voix plus rien ce sont les
pixels buzz ouhlala effet spécial c'est
de la magie la pixel bugs à serris
pixels buzz a vachement cool & pixel
buzz à tout marche ensemble écosystèmes
on en parle vous allez voir ça et vous
allez pouvoir les gagner alors pour les
gagner c'est très très facile il suffit
d'envoyer un email juste un email
d'accord l'image les mii dans le top
chatte vous envoyer un petit mail jeu
avec un x à la fin je concours fnac @
gmail point com vous envoyer votre nom
votre prénom et vous envoyer le code
pixel juste ça vous marquez pixels code
pixels alors après vous pouvez marquer
bonjour je suis content code pixels je
veux gagner je participe et après
pouvait raconter votre vie ben volera
moi
j'adore j'adore pixels doit de plus je
veux mon pixel voit la bonne et moi et
mon pixel je ferai en telle année j'ai
tout fait d'angles et encore j'ai plus
de regrets j'ai pas que vous les avez
pas voilà enfin bref tout va bien et on
en reparle donc le concours vous avez ça
c'est en top en top commentaires dans le
chat à les y participer vous êtes les
bienvenus c'est un petit cadeau c'est
pour nous ça fait plaisir et vous allez
vous amuser parce que effectivement vous
allez pouvoir les attacher dans deux
jours avec les moins 100 euros mais si
vous pouvez le gagner c'est quand même
un peu mieux comme ça vous garder
l'argent pour vous sympathique alors on
va rentrer dans le vif du sujet parce
que jimmy là tout de suite et déjà 18h35
ça fait déjà presque 5 minutes qu'on est
en train de parler ça passe très très
vite et vous allez voir qu'il ya
tellement de choses à dire tellement de
choses à dire que ça va être
complètement fou alors on y va on a
plusieurs choses à voir c'est vrai on va
déjà parié un euro déjà je vous montrais
un truc parce que là effectivement ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui ce sont les les
emballages tu peux ouvrir ces trucs-là
s'te plaît
enfin un peu de la magie jeux louverain
ouvre ouvre paf à la bolivie on l'a
enlevé la boîte ont alors vous allez
gagner ça ouais la boîte vous avez des
écouteurs avec ça c'est plutôt
intéressant qui vont être livrés dont
c'est quoi cette espèce du sur boîte
mais en réalité les boîtes ce sont
celles-là pixels six pixels syspro bon
pour les buzz il ya pas de surba pascal
déjà des bleus des bosses et des oiseaux
pas mettre des écouteurs avec ça paraît
assez logique jusque là je pense qu'on
est bon donc voyez donc ça c'est cool et
en réalité là vous avez ça mais les
smartphones ils sont là tu as ton
smartphone toi bien sûr oh la la
les tatamis les coques de protection de
suisse bien sûr puisqu'on va loin
monsieur a pas envie de casser son
téléphone qu'il adore d'ailleurs il est
beau alors après un sublime
en même temps on comme on l'est dans le
direct on va pas se cacher des bons la
boîte je la prends trois heures à ranger
la boîte non plus le dr est à la version
qui est protégé et moi j'ai des versions
nues totalement nue comme ça regarde et
hop alors attendez on va faire un truc
parce que comme on est en direct je vais
bouger j'ai visité parce que tout à
l'heure
voilà voilà météo parisienne safran mr
bah oui c'est ça je suis technicien
animateur en paix tout en même temps
voyez c'est du fait maison on est entre
nous c'est du fait maison donc on a la
possibilité de la voir comme ça donc ça
il ya deux couleurs en fait il faut le
savoir les dénomination exacte je
reprends parce que tout est écrit ci il
ya des dénominations particulière c'est
le noir carbone ça c'est le noir carbone
il existe également le gris océans on
n'a pas de grease océans mais si mais si
vous voulez voir les grilles océans
allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil soit
sur le style de google pour avoir plein
d'infos sur ces pixels mais vous allez
les avoir ici soyez rassurés ou alors
directement sur le site de la fnac une
fois de plus je vous ai mis des liens en
bas dans la description pour cliquer à
les voir et ça c'est soit tu es d'accord
jim est tout à fait 6000 euros c'est
bien on se pose les prix
il fait du spoiler si vous regardez une
série vous lui vous ne regardez pas avec
lui va vous spoiler heureusement que je
t'ai dit avant le lac de ba tabler sur
la table
et le bec il est batteur je pense que
quelques acteurs des musiciens des
batteurs n'ont même pas c'est vrai dire
elle est efficace des trucs
savall ok alors on y va deux smartphones
un peu différent pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement on a un format qui est
un peu différent mais deux smartphones
que je te laisse faire la speakerine des
mains jimmy de speakerine supercar de
smartphones un peu différent mais hyper
hyper canon alors là au dos vous le
voyez peut-être pas mais moi je vais
vous le dire vous avez un verre corning
gorilla glass hills qui veulent protéger
à l'avancé du virtus parce qu'on n'est
pas là pour se marrer on va reprendre un
peu les specs et on va regarder un peu
ce qu'il a dans le ventre ce smartphone
mais surtout ce qui nous intéresse ici
comme on est chez google et bien c'est
toute la partie os c'est à dire la
partie logicielle on est sur l'android
pur pour l'instant c'est que l'android
12 entre la bêta distendre u13 est
disponible pour ceux qui ont un pixel
alice a voulu tester si vous voulez
sinon avec la batterie
sinon vous verrez que android xiii
arrivera bientôt avec plein de super
fonctionnalités hyper canon alors qu'est
ce qu'il raconte c'est son affaire en
date deux formant un petit peu différent
fait voir lequel elle comme ils se
ressemblent beaucoup des fois il faut
vraiment les mettre côte à côte pour
savoir lequel est le plus grand cas les
plus petits alors vous avez
hop là sont des écrans oled on assure du
vase justement que le pixel si c'est
celui là je ne lui fais tu as fait ta
petite
le pixel 6c du site de 4 pouces on est
sur du full hd plus aucun fléchissement
de 90 heures nous avons fait passer un
petit peu le truc tandis que sur l'autre
eh bien on va avoir du 6 7 pouces oled
ltp haut c'est à dire un taux de
rafraîchissement variable on va jusqu'à
120 hertz quad hd plus grosse résolution
plutôt cool sympa haut parleurs stéréo
regarder en plus ils sont vachement bien
destinée à faire toute ma vie je pense
que tu as une carrière ya moyen grave
moyens grave moyens ce qui nous
intéresse surtout ici c'est la puce
maison google c'est la première fois je
te le dire le nom ce que tu là google
tensor donc premières puces maisons de
chez google donc là tout est fait google
à l'intérieur et c'est une première chez
google c'est ça qui est intéressant en
fait si vous voulez parce que google
fait du google et du goût qui peut mieux
se servir que google pour savoir ce
qu'il leur faut est ce qu'il faut mettre
dans leur puce donc en fait ils ont
complètement optimisé la puce pour avoir
une expérience maison totalement fluide
totalement optimisé on va regarder tout
ce qu'on peut bien faire parce qu'à
plein de choses qu'on peut venir faire
en plus de pouvoir l'allumer et
l'éteindre ça c'est la fonction de base
vous allez voir ça c'est vachement cool
google tensor 5 g bien évidemment j'ai
sur les deux modèles ouais donc ça c'est
bien donc si vous voulez de la saine
gestion chouette en plus d'avoir de la
scène de viol à du wifi 6 on a dit wifi
6 tout à fait donc en termes de rapidité
ça va ça va booster un les
téléchargements vous allez voir ça va
vraiment être cool d'artisanat estimé on
n'a pas le temps il n'a pas le temps
google il est comme ugta qui va vite
arrête de faire de la base qui sont sept
sur le torse quand tu sens que tu es ma
tu sais plus quoi en faire il ya quand
même un bateau cela que si je pêche
agréable on est mal n'y a plus rien on
va la halle alors dit on à la table de
mixage va tout va partir de tous les
côtés et après il ya un autre truc qu'a
fait google qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils ont rajouté une deuxième fois par
le coprocesseur de sécurité c'est le
titan m2 qui tombe du coup c on en est
un peu parlé ce qui est très drôle c'est
que du coup c'est un coffre fort ouais
dans lequel on a mis un autre coffre
fort est là pour la rca tu fais ta comme
ça ce schéma dans le dos de sa ville
camisole ça stresse un peu vous amuser à
jaca serait pas à ses premiers jardins
danser pour vos petites oreilles avoue
surtout excusez moi voilà pardon et il
lui restait rien ce soir c'est promis en
fait l'idée de la titan m2 si vous
voulez c'est d'abord comme un coffre
fort inviolable et je vous lis que j'ai
noté la sa terrasse en fait c'est une
puce qui est un dérivé un dérivé du
système de sécurité des data center
google dont qu'ils ont mis dans ce
smartphone est ça qui est intéressant
fait dans ce sens dans ses smartphones
ils ont mis du vrai concentré de google
miniaturisés et un petit coffre-fort
google qui vient du data center qui est
ailleurs qu'il vient jouer vraiment pour
la sécurité contre le hameçonnage vont
forcément les fichiers il fabrique donc
vous êtes [ __ ] vous êtes tranquille et
donc ça c'est plutôt chouette un bon
après on a une plus grosse batterie
forcément dans le six pros forcément on
est sur une batterie de 5 min on perd
contre 4,6 sur le normal et dans les
deux cas ça vous fait tenir une bonne
journée une journée et demie sur l'autre
utilisation et ça c'est vraiment super
cool et après on a un mode super
économies d'énergie qui nous font peser
jusqu'à deux jours voilà si toutefois on
sent un petit peu à plat et qu'on dit
oui il va falloir faire des concessions
mais ça marche vraiment très très bien
ouais c'est hyper hyper canon charge
sans fil est également bon on vous passe
un petit peu le truc très rapidement au
niveau de la photo date une poussée de
la photo parce qu'il ya vraiment une
différence on vous fait à la halle et
pète tout on vous demande c'est comme ça
et vous allez voir après en fait elle
est vraie différence alors le pixel six
pixels 6 first hockey grand-angle dans
les deux cas c'est la même chose sur la
base d'un grand-angle de 50 négatif
c'est rien que sur les deux pièces et
ultra grand-angle de 12 mégapixels
autofocus laser stabilisation optique
donc ça c'est plutôt cool mais oh là là
là là monsieur mais sur toi tu fais ça
tu trouvais ça tellement bien tu t'es
fait une manucure avant de venir parce
que je mangerai tu vois je suis déçu
j'aurais dû faire
le tri et alors on continue on est à
l'autre le pro alors là on a un truc en
plus d'y aller voir six nouveautés voilà
le téléobjectif là le téléobjectif
ouais et ça c'est vraiment très très
calé à l'envi il est là car hélas c'est
lui ces gros téléobjectif tel objectif
avec 48 mégapixels 48 mégapixels on a un
zoom optique x 4 et on peut aller
jusqu'aux fois vendu berric voilà sinon
vous vous rapprochez a prudemment il
faut tendre les bras y arriver donc le
truc qui est intéressant il ya une
différence aussi au niveau des caméras
de celle fille on est sur du 8 versus de
11,1 impressionner pas là pour rigoler
et il faut que ça a été pendant les sept
fils groupe c'est ça donc du coup on
peut certes du grand-angle pour prendre
une photo un peu plus large qu'en fins
elle fit donc celle fit seul c'est cool
ça de fait à plusieurs c'est encore
mieux et là pour le coup de téléphone il
sait le faire et ça c'est top exactement
donc ça c'est chouette et arrête avec
tes mains sans j'ai vraiment coupé g
léger la cuisine pas loin là j'ai décidé
de venir suivre en live gore quand même
six mois je l'avais qui tapait la coupe
les bras c'est dégueulasse non on est
des gens bien et des gens ça alors
n'oubliez pas je vous le redis il ya le
jeu concours attention je voulais pas
mener vous pouvez y aller vous aurez
votre email vous envoyez votre email
pour tenter de gagner un pixel 6 et des
pixels bugs a donc ça c'est hyper cadre
où les hippies n'oubliez pas du 27 mai
au 19 juin 100 euros de remise en vo
pixels six pixels six pros il faut
garder l'infante et parce que c'est
intéressant alors je vous passe un peu
côté très technique de ce smartphone on
a un petit peu vu les grands points
après j'ai fait une vidéo pour aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil pour tout
savoir là dessus moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est les fonctionnalités parce que les
fonctionnalités d'un paquet ils sont
hyper canon un mouchard jimmy alors le
fer pendant qu'il fait la différence
aujourd'hui par rapport au mans où il
est sorti fin octobre maintenant le
téléphone il ya beaucoup évolué et c'est
presque plus si c'est le même il a
changé il a grandi il a évolué la
prématurité là vous allez découvrir on a
fait des choses un petit peu trop sur
lui de tenir les mains tu te rends
compte que tu deviens fou avec tes mains
est ce que tu es et tu étais tu étais
d'été du sud toi t'es pas un peu italien
t'as pas un truc comme ça à non pas du
tout mal pas écrémage pas le bon si je
parle beaucoup avec mes mains je joue
comme ça bien
taper sur les tables je me taperais pu
s'essayer sait s'arrêter au top alors il
ya des fonctionner comme tu le disais
qu'ils sont arrivés on appelle ça les
filles turques joie là on aime bien
garder les anglicismes mais vous avez
des fonctionnalités de base déjà parce
que deux bases quand il est sorti il
était super cool parce qu'il y avait
plein de choses hyper cool a montré il
ya des choses qui n'étaient pas
disponibles avant donc par exemple on
pense à la gomme magique ouais donc sans
processeur de google bas ce serait je
pense pas possible c'est le seul à le
faire aujourd'hui
via le mode mouvement qui soit un vrai
pas un petit dépôt de gomme magique tout
à l'heure on a regardé ça on a tout
repris au tollé des mecs hyper beau se
redresser
on a repris tout on a dit elle on va
tous reprendre tout sort mais on se met
un jour et on a gommé des choses et
j'ai vu à ce moment là que tu étais un
goût amer de dames toi alors comme je go
je dois me vois tu dégomme les tableaux
ci à cancun est justement
à cette magnifique photo part exacte à
tanger ont reçu un petit coucou dans le
tchad je regarde un peu qui est là le
chat a pas ce qu'il faut savoir que le
live et diffuser bien évidemment sur ma
chaîne youtube sur fnac.com et également
sur twitter de la fnac on a un peu
partout attention regardez chez vous on
est partout il se peut qu'on soit
derrière vous entraînez vous à banon
n'est pas là on est devant vous alors je
sais ma blague est pourri je regarde un
très joli message on a des sous thèmes
je remercie
il va être mon futur smartphone le site
promet on voit on n'a que des trucs pas
positif salut à vous deux je peux faire
actuellement ok je regarde non mais
c'est cool au monsieur gros comment vois
tu je vais très bien coucou à tous on
est tout de suite 7 264 62 en direct
vous êtes nombreux nombreuses merci à
vous d'être là on va continuer ce live
ensemble et on va regarder ses
différentes fonctions et et on va
commencer par celles qui étaient déjà
disponibles au moment de la sortie du
smartphone on y va on passe top shot est
prêt ouais binômes ont transporté les
logiques du coup petite photo d'un
événement passé près de la gare
saint-lazare on va jouer un petit peu
vous allez voir je vais je vais me
rapprocher de toi parce que tu as une
fois de plus en bas voilà comme ça
les voilà olalala en événements il y
avait un dragon il s'est échappé il
était sur la gare saint lazare ouais et
bah je trouve quand même sur cette photo
il ya quand même beaucoup d'intervenants
qui voit là un dragon il serait mieux
tout seul il ya des gens qui sont venus
ce que s'incruster dans le truc quoi
plus jeunes comme plus il ya une petite
proposition il fallait face et les
personnes dans leurs plans ba écoute
face et une suggestion de gomme magique
enfin je gérais montrent ces personnes
mais voilà je décide de les effacer de
ma photo parce que voilà je passais en
paraissant pas tes poteaux exactement où
se trouve le dragon il va s'en occuper
peut-être pas envie clarifier sa
position donc là en fait c'est des
suggestions qui vient de faire c'est ça
donc là il me dit là il a le le tensor à
vue qui avait des gens en arrière-plan
il a vu qu'il y avait un premier enfin
le avait comme une exposition sur le
premier saut premier plan le dragon donc
je vais tous les effacer pour avoir
juste mondragon attends je recule un peu
comment tu fais vas-y montre donc je
vais juste up l'a appuyé sur tout
effacer et boum magie et ils sont partis
donc je peux enregistrer ma photo
donc ça c'est cool ça et ça c'est cool
et même si je joue mais comme vous
pouvez voir volaille faut vraiment aller
dans le pixel près pour voir qui s'est
passé quelque chose mais c'est ultra
props et ultra cali est ok ça permet
d'avoir des photos vous êtes honnête du
monde où passait dans la rue vous avez
un événement vous êtes avec votre
famille prenez une photo de vos proches
il ya beaucoup de monde r ça vous gêne
un petit peu et ben non on fait
disparaître les gens et la personne est
tout seul et le seul monde et ça c'est
trop bien pour les fait partie alors
après il y avait une autre
fonctionnalité qui avait mis en avant
google et qui est intéressant c'est ce
qu'on appellera leur hilton wilton leur
hilton alors wilson lourd
merci c'est mon propre nom et en plus tu
le fait vachement m refait leur hilton
walton tenter plus fidèles amis de
l'histoire
est en fait ce rythme il est intéressant
pourquoi parce qu en fait google s'est
dit ok ça c'est d'un côté très inclusif
et ils ont raison à 400% les smartphones
quand ils font des photos ils vont
plutôt enfin il faisait il les adapter
pour les personnes de peau blanche et on
pensait pas aux personnes qui avaient
des pots de couleurs et m du coup c'est
un petit pas blanchir les pots et ça
fonctionnait pas c'était pas beau donc
il ya eu un vrai travail algorithmique
qui a été fait avec une reconnaissance
dépôt est ce qui fait que le rendu qu'on
a et b en fait c'est vraiment la teinte
de peau de la personne et ça ça marche
c'était vraiment un truc con qui paraît
tout bête quand on en parle comme ça
mais c'était pas le cas donc ça c'est
chouette c'est super important qu'il le
fasse parce que du coup il y en a ils
voulaient prendre les photos et les
photos c'est les souvenirs et si vous
souvenir sans altérer malheureusement
c'est un peu dommage non j'ai pas non ça
marche pas et voilà c'est toujours bien
de se retrouver sous son meilleur jour
et tout le monde tout le monde peut être
beau jeu vous étiez vous avant mais là
vous serez bout tout le temps bien c'est
génial si vous quand il parle comme ça
parce que je dirais qu'on montre un
petit peu toute la côte et
fonctionnalité l'application de deux
photos il ya plusieurs modes intéressant
notamment le mode mouvement alors vous
le montrez rapidement parce que là ici
police passe pas trop de choses autour
de nous donc bon mais ces histoires
venir regarder alors hop la pac on y va
à tanger désole un peu plan là j'en ai
des fous donc excusez moi donc la t100
l'appareil un peu classique va ta photo
hop le mouvement au tabac avance un peu
ton smartphone parce que on le voit pas
forcément très très bien dans le menu
voilà donc j'étais sur appareil photo
ouais je trouve un peu sur la gauche et
la boum le mouvement humain mais ben
alors il apporte quoi ce mode mouvement
chers amis alors le mode mouvement
justement ça permet
d'avoir excusez moi le mode mouvement ça
permet d'avoir toujours avoir votre
sujet net way est également on a une
deuxième onglet juste l'argent vient
tout juste la plage était là j'étais là
oui il pose longue ça veut dire que si
jacques le sens mouvement par le jeu
marche mon arrière l'arrière de mon
arrière plan va être un peu flou si je
prends une voiture mais du coup je peux
faire un mode nous un mode pause long
comme ça ma voiture va paraître en
mouvement et ça donne ce petit côté un
peu vivant au téléphone aux photos et
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve pas
forcément ailleurs en tout cas sur un
smartphone aujourd'hui c'est hyper canon
donc vous voyez il ya plein de petites
fonctionnalités qui ont été mises en
avant parce que google fait du google a
donc effectivement c'est tout quotas
gorrite mais qui est mis en avant alors
là on se parle de ça mais il ya un autre
truc est hyper hyper canon c'est toute
la côte et traduction est ce que des
traductions il ya vachement de choses à
raconter à ses incroyables en fait
l'idée de google c'est de se dire ok on
est tous sur une planète et on parle pas
la même langue jusque là je pense que
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes on le sait
tous mais comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour rendre la communication plus
simple à côté de chez nous ou alors
lorsqu'on part en voyage pour venir
comprendre des choses il ya beaucoup de
choses au niveau de la traduction alors
on a déjà on va regarder la traduction
instantanée à l'oral lorsque par exemple
au vaille dans un endroit où on se
comprend pas avec la personne on se fait
une petite démo on prend un smartphone
n'est en rien de sa joue maintenant on
peut le faire avec les bucks et on va
aller plus loin on va épurer leurs
matchs de ne dégager une oreille et je
vais me mettre un bug d'à côté hop là
soyons fou peut toujours nous les
oreilles alors attends je vais prendre
au plat celui là hop là j'entends dans
mon oreille il s'est passé quelque chose
à il me parle
j'ai redit
raconte des choses de fou j'ai
l'impression en fait tu voyais excusez
nous on a un petit blanc ce masque en
fait j'ai il en train de me parler de
notification et tous ok ok c'est parfait
alors on va y aller on va se faire la
traduction instantanée pour ça on a une
nappe c'est ça
tu peux nous montrer
alors là règlement dans la gueule voilà
au pl
oui tous google traduit en baisse dans
les oreilles ils sont plus là -selon les
oreilles c'est normal et l'application
traduction en fait un crs du coup je
vais dans conversations ouais et ça
c'est bien je ouais donc pas ça te parle
hop là moi je vais me mettre au sud non
je peux aussi appuyé sur mes écouteurs
ouais j'ai un petit peu aide moi à
parler espagnol ah ouais challenge
voilà c'est magnifique et maintenant on
va passer en mode on me dit tu parlais
très bien espagnol c'est à bla bla bla
bla bla modèle espagnol pour graver au
port et déco
micasa et tout cas ça c'est beau ce que
fut dit ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai donc
on va voir le mode conversation vont
pouvoir échanger directement de toi à
moi et ça c'est plutôt cool je vais
plutôt me roger meece pagnol onglet tu
préfères nom espagnol espagnol moi je
pense que c'est bien ça me donne un peu
plus de soleil tu vois que si on pense
au royaume uni avec un peu plus de
chavanette anglais traité charge parce
qu'en fait c'était pâques à venir
télégéniques comme ça quand vous avez
vos packs directement dedans vous est
peinard vous êtes tranquille alors nous
avons un petit mot de conversation c'est
cela c'est cela donc moi je vais te
parler en anglais il parle super bien
old is my taylor is rich exactement très
riche royer ok on y va
eyebe ayissi day
voir si mon accent est pourri ou pas
tant visible mais la caméra là où
donc là ça m'a traduit dans les oreilles
je sais exactement je dis fais ok on y
va en fait cette année à sept amis
locataires mais là on est un peu floue
là sur le top shot revient là voilà
voilà au qu'il reste est ok rigaud
hockey remettant remet un petit coup là
que je te dise quelque chose
non tu as quelqu'un qui est riche ou non
obama et taylor is rich
voir lots baby attend bel et bien là
qu'on le voit voilà et label'vie hawaï
et au t4 à guipavas traduit on a dû
faire une
bonne amie ouais je traduis l'anglais à
l'anglais c'est le gars il a un profil
très violent de la dre ah voilà it's
working and it's working j'en sais
degrees backward il dit je vais
ok donc voyez un peu le truc c'est super
intéressant parce que ça permet de
converser avec des gens très facilement
au plat on va retirer sa amigo ça permet
de converser très très facilement alors
là vous l'avez effectivement et bien au
plat je me donnais deux auraient coucou
salue on peut le voir directement en
venant échanger avec quelqu'un mais on
l'a également avec google lance
directement pour un bocage un bouquin à
les bouger pour
commencer j'ai récupéré hier c'est ce
bouquin là alors ça c'est tout en
anglais donc tout le dos est écrit en
anglais donc l'a fait nous la montre
nous avec des marines up
voit la photo je vais aller dans l'aisne
saelens voilà l anti fait plein de
choses l'aisne ce qui traduit donc si je
vais dans un pays un peu étrange et j'ai
besoin de voir la composition des
ingrédients il rappela je me déplace si
tu veux je joue un peu
fatiguée un peu le font parce que
ils l'ont montré j'ai vu sur des démos
ou effectivement deux fois dans un
restaurant dans un pays je pense moi
l'asie parce qu'autant l'anglais
j'arrive encore à je comprends je le
parle n'y a pas de souci mais mais moi
tu vas me m je vais aller en corée par
exemple tu allant corriger tes largué
complet en corée je ne sais rien lire je
ne comprends pas et ça c'est génial
parce que ça permet vraiment de dire ok
ah ok ça c'est là ça c'est ça je
comprends un peu ce qui se passe et je
suis vraiment largués donc ça c'est
quand même vachement bien et du coup tu
te retrouves à manger des trucs un petit
peu extrême ou pas il ya du piment n'en
est pas là on m'avait proposé d'aller
manger c'était quoi c'était du poulpe
vivant tu le prends acte et baguettes et
ufo le rsa faut l'avaler c'est un
concept alors le seul risque qui a c'est
que le pool qui se déploie dans ta gorge
est là et pas très bien à s'affairer ça
fait envie voilà est en fait il va être
brûlés des sucs gastriques il est
digérée directement vous fait gagner un
poulpe ce soir à l'as monaco type koth
poulpe on voyait un poulpe dont le voyez
il ya pas mal de traduction il aura pris
à d'autres systèmes de traduction qu'on
va appeler la traduction à la volée vous
écoutez un peu de casse vous allez avec
votre bouton de volume c'est pouvoir
traduire directement il ya plein de
solutions de traduction de tous les
côtés lors d'un appel lorsque vous êtes
passé à quelqu'un traduire du texte vous
repérer donc ça c'est vachement cool
vous avez également un autre cas
d'agression si c'est la transcription la
transcription c'est tellement je range
mon bouquin je le lirai
et la transcription c'est hyper canon
pourquoi parce que ça va vous permettre
aux plates on va y aller on y va attaque
tu nous montres bim par l'appliquer non
tu n'as pas à temps je remets comme ça
on est pas sacro la traduction n'était
pas loin sur la transcription sur
l'application enregistreurs à
l'enregistrer sur l'application
enregistrant servir transcrire et ça va
venir enregistrer votre texte en fait ce
qui fait que et hop là il faut que je
parle dans mon téléphone
you have to speak in your téléphone
absolutely anything is in french please
ils se complètent les flous c'est pas
parce que vous êtes sous vous rassurer
vous voilà tout va bien de savoir qui
part donc avec l'eau tout va bien vas-y
donc là on fait ça on enregistre et donc
y avoir une transcription bienvenus
comment ça va tout va bien
et donc là on voit dans le truck
transcription un plan interne a dit
comment ça va tout va bien pardon et
donc ça c'est génial alors ça à
plusieurs fonctionnalités le but par
exemple c'est que lorsque vous vous êtes
jean sérien brin professionnel et que
vous voulez faire de la dictée et bien
votre texte va se poser là alors ce
qu'il faut faire quand même c'est une
bonne diction attention mais des temps
mais des respirations fait pas comme -
bouffe pas la moitié des mots mais ça
vous permet effectivement d'avoir ce
côté là qui est pratique donc voyez
c'est plein de petites fonctionnalités
qui arrive il y en a une autre qui est
aussi sympa au niveau de la photo c'est
la fonctionnalité top shot voilà c'est à
dire qu'en fait vous venez l'activation
de votre caméra s'est pas activée ça va
vous faire une photo et ça vous dire à
26 ans il ya eu tel petit truc avant tes
petits trucs après nous on te recommande
cette photo là c'est la meilleur tu la
seleccion est comme ça tu es parti pour
40 ans et c'est vachement et aura une
belle photo prenez celle que vous voulez
en réalité pas de problème il n'y a pas
de problème est que des solutions
la batterie adaptative également qui est
intéressante la batterie intelligente
grâce à la puce google tensor qui va
venir s'adapter à vos usages qui connaît
vos usages qui apprend vos usages autour
un peu dans l'idée l'intelligent et l'ia
et qui va venir complètement s'optimiser
pour aller plus loin et vous permettre
de gagner en autonomie jour après jour
donc ça aussi c'est chouette et puis on
a aussi un mode jeu je pas si vous êtes
gamer on peut aller sur youtube on peut
souligner sur youtube faire des captures
ne pas déranger ou sur votre parti
tranquille dans votre coin voulez pas
qu'on vous embête voulez pas qu'on vous
embêtait exactement en fait une petite
partie d'un jeu en ligne avec vos potes
voulaient un stream et pour montrer vos
meilleur shoot ba écoute et pourquoi pas
le téléphone il le fait avec votre mémé
votre pp voulait défier à tenir comme ça
vous traquent les jungles clac clac clac
clac on est pas mal donc voilà un peu
pour ses fonctionnalités de base et au
delà de ça il y en a d'autres qui sont
rajoutés mais juste avant on va aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil dans le tchat
chers amis je regarde un petit peu
pixels si c'est le meilleur je peux te
pose une question tu peux pose une
question comment on sait le gagnant
alors je pense jérémy que le nom du
gagnant tu seras communiquer par email
il y aura un tirage au sort bien
évidemment parce que sinon ce serait
trop facile vous retirer vous aurez un
message le tirage au sort pour le
concours aura lieu quand renault je n'ai
pas la question tu peut adresser la
question directement dans ton mail quand
tu écris quand est ce qu'on aura lieu le
tirage au sort ils seront un plaisir de
te répondre et de donner toutes ces
informations là
je regarde un petit peu vos petits
messages est ce qu'il ya un modérateur
pour répondre à la question jérémy donc
je pense que je viens de répondre à ta
question donc ça c'est bon c'est bon
aussi on fait tout temps du tout maison
mode ont fait modérateurs ont fait
réalisation fait animation fait tout on
est dégueu d'un petit message de nestor
super ton anglais tu as vu on a vraiment
quand même bien bossé
lyès english in english in english
voilà bah écoutez ses coups il ya du
monde est il disponible en haïti je ne
sais pas kevin ça c'est une tu me pose
une colle je ne sais pas du tout comment
on fait pour sandra gagnon leclerc de
seclin plein question voilà donc voilà
peu provocation n'hésitez pas à poser
vos questions si vous avez des questions
des idées des expériences que vous les
partager sur votre pixels pixels 6 ou
générations antérieures parce que les
fonctionnalités dont on va parler dans
quelques instants et bien certaines sont
exclues
pixels 6 à voir mais il y en a qui vont
arriver que vous avez même s'ils
préfèrent des pixels 3.763 j'ai fait
lire le mec qui sait même plus qui
raconte pixels 3 donc on va regarder ses
fonctions et et qui sont nouvelles ce
qu'on appelle les futurs groupes alors
les futurs drogue pour vouloir faire en
fait tous les trois mois qui donnent
tous les trois mois tous les deux mois
pas tous les mois pas tous les six mois
tous les 3 mois vous avez une nouvelle
fonctionnalité qui arrive une ou
plusieurs nouvelles fonctionnalités et
elles sont super intéressante parce
qu'elles viennent augmenter l'expérience
parce que auchan jimmy quand on vient
acheter un smartphone on le prend on a
des mises à jour de sécurité de temps en
temps on la petite mise à jour mais
c'est plutôt rare et un smartphone
apporte de nouvelles fonctionnalités et
viennent se réinventer et ça c'est
vraiment ce qui se passe là pour le coup
google y rajoute plein de choses
les futurs d'europe tous les trois mois
tu vas arrêter de taper dossier de
nabeul a comme ça tu aimes bien du coup
non vraiment il rajoute beaucoup de
choses intéressantes je pense par
exemple à la détection de l'accident de
voiture et ça c'est vraiment très cool
le mode nuit qu'on peut directement au
pied sur snapshot pour ceux qui
s'adaptent franchement vous allez voir
c'est vraiment top il ya plein d'autres
choses qui m'échappent globale et
détaillée la garde je voudrais que moi
patins à parler justement la détection
d'accidents ça c'est un truc qui a tiqué
qui je vous le souhaite à personne
attention non non non mais je ne serai
pas le test bondir est un surtout pas
mais ça marche mais ça marche alors
montre nous ton sur ton pixels six gros
comment ça fonctionne parce qu'en fait
le truc si vous voulez il faut
s'imaginer vous êtes vous roulez vous
avez un carton et vous êtes seul et
c'est la galère donc qu'est ce que peut
faire votre smartphone et bien va
pouvoir appeler déjà vous demandez vous
comment est-ce que ça va et va pouvoir
appeler les secours c'est quand même
plutôt par là j'ai envie de vous dire tu
ok alors montre nourou se trouve
l'application déjà dans un premier temps
on va se passer sur la caméra du au tac
on y va monsieur doit monsieur main aux
plats à temps je te des zooms un peu
voilà bon alors c'est déjà là parce que
j'ai déjà regardé mais on va marquer
sécurité aidant sécurité où j'ai ici bon
j'ai pas tout acte iv 1 j'ai pas envie
re ah bon en europe là j'ai pas envie de
rentrer plus dans providence sinon on va
dire non je te le sens que je peux
active et là on le voit pas montre le
nous postons téléphone à plat la limite
si tu veux voilà donc tu me permets
ouais je viens on recentre un peu tac
tac tac c'est un peu haussé en fait
c'est un peu loin de nous si vous voulez
mais comme ça comme on fait ça comme ça
je pense que là t'es pas mal alors ok
l'application on se retrouve ici comment
ça se passe mal donc quand je suis sur
l'application la provence l'ouvrir
mouvement de la configurer donc faire
des petits tests étaient des mots le
téléphone va d'abord se mettre à sonner
ouais pour savoir si on a un tel statut
qu'on peut bien faire ou pas eux mais en
fait j'ai pas fini la démo donc c'est
pour ça que ça fait un peut contrôler la
situation
bon j'ai pas envie ben ali deux res
alors à temps parce que moi je n'ai pas
testé sur
mon pixel 6 dont je pense que soit le
pixel 6g pouvoir vous le montrer parce
que la démo elle est extrêmement
parlante comme ça vous allez voir bouger
pas sécurité hop hop hop je vais dans
mon application sécurité je continue
avec mon compte est-ce qu'il faut que je
rentre mon mon groupe sanguin bien sûr
je lai tu là oh lalala lalala
si j'arrête pas si t'arrêtes pas ses
bazars il appelle ouais alors attends
bouge pas
la police arrive galella
mais la terre auraient été collectées la
whey
déconnecté ok on est en direct
ok ça marche
tac tac tac tac tac découvrez la
détection d'accidents va essayer le mode
démo le mode démo il est la tacc bouge
pas essayer le mode démo démarré lorsque
vous utilisez l'application
voilà il donc là il va vous demander si
vous allez bien vous si vous n'allez pas
bien
vous avez configuré vous avez juste à
pied cinq fois sur le bouton d'allumage
voilà et du coup ça va lancer le mode
exactement donc vous dites je vais bien
à l'oral tout va bien pas d'accident un
accident mineur ou alors appelé dit
cette note là vous êtes conscient mais
si vous n'êtes pas conscient lui qu'est
ce qu'il va faire eh bien il va
directement appelé la police et du coup
bon bain normalement la police va
débarquer va arriver et va vous sauver
la vie lagravère l'idée ils arrivent ils
arrivent ça s'arrangerait on serait un
petit peu embêté donc ça c'est pour la
détection d'un accident donc ça c'est un
truc qui va choix pertinent en fait
parce que ça vient vraiment enrichi à
l'expérience et ça peut sauver donc
c'est cool il ya notre mode qui est cool
qui arrivait ya pas longtemps à
l'entente sur la détection d'accidents
ça c'est arrivé au mois de décembre il
ya notre mode qui arrivait soit pas là
au mois de décembre c'est la
fonctionnalité en écoute en écoute
alors toi tu écoutes quoi montre nous en
fait le truc c'est tout bête votre
smartphone si vous l'autorisez il va
venir écouter en permanence là
la musique et il va vous dire tiens ça
c'est tel morceau en fait c'est un
shazam en fait que vous avez derrière
c'est un peu l'idée d'un shazam et ça va
venir vous dire et douce à voulangis
directement ici il valait un peu plus
loin ouais donc là en écoute vous avez
juste à l'activer dans son unification
way eux mêmes en racheter un petit
tableau petites icônes sur votre fond
d'écran ouais et là du coup c'est tout
ce qu'il a entendu autour de moi or ce
qui est très drôle c'est qu'il a entendu
des choses quand je regardais la télé
quand je regarde des séries ouais et je
peux retrouver des musiques et j'ai
juste à cliquer dessus pour retrouver
mes musiques sur spotify sur deezer se
déplace en téléchargement légal et je
peux les écouter quand je veux donc si
cette musique m'a plu aux asticots à la
musique pop et maintenant c'est celle-là
il a entendu ouais rentrer dans un
endroit sans une musique d'un magasin
dans la rue dans un restaurant est bien
plus rude pour écouter cette musique
partout et ça c'est vraiment top et ça
vous le stock est voilé du coup vous
avez tous deux tout dans le téléphone il
réfléchit votre place c'est top alors il
ya un truc qui est assez canon qui
arrivait alors attendez j'ai les dates
là je regarde en même temps ça arrive au
mois de décembre c'est la fonction
double appui fait c'est un double tap
qu'on fait derrière capturés ouais et ça
vient enregistrer ce que vous voit face
à un paramètre en fait c'est comme un
bouton en plus vous tapez 2 fois ode au
tac tac et ça vous fait quelque chose
soit tu la paramétrer sur quoi je les
paramétrer sur capture d'écran hockey
plutôt top donc là c'est la fameuse
liste on écoute on va pouvoir fusionner
la plage et en dollar donc je vais juste
taper tak tak deux fois alors la petite
astuce un redoutable kull un peu parce
que ok mon astuce et de taper sur le
logo google wave 1 2
et à cette fin une capture d'écran et là
hop il m'a fait une capture hockey canon
donc la toiture amiantée pur d'écran moi
j'ai admis une application pour ça
m'ouvre youtube et après on peut mettre
plein le sosa peu appelé l'assistant
google ça sera plein plein de trucs
c'est vous qui voyez hein c'est vraiment
selon votre préférence et ouais il faut
aller dans system danger qui peut nous
montrer ça commence à peu se paramétrer
en allant dans system d'hangest
up tient dans le temps mais la caméra au
dessus
je sais plus
alors
si tu vas dans tes paramètres double
regard voilà utilisé le double appui
voilà tout simplement vas-y pose
pourquoi je cherche beaucoup double
appui ouais sur quoi je peux le faire
capture d'écran accès à votre assistant
numérique mettre en pause des contenus
multimédias ou à l'api récente afficher
une association vrinat pis moi j'aime
bien capture d'écran c'est un peu
ludique c'est sympa et tu fais souvent
des captures d'écran ouais c'est pas mal
pour boulot ça peut être un certain mais
qui capturent brouage capture ou chien
s'est montrée ces chasseurs de pokémon
c'est exactement ça j'ai reconnu tout de
suite il ya un autre truc qui est
intéressant qui arrivait alors qu'ils
arrivent et quand toujours au mois de
décembre c'est la clef de voiture
numérique dans la voiture arive la
voiture arrive à peu près à l arrivée
lesquels arrivent on le fait en fait ça
marche pas avec toutes les toutes les
marques de voitures et tous les modèles
mais si vous avez un véhicule qui va
être compatibles le truc qui est
intéressant pourquoi et bien parce qu'en
fait ça permettra de garder uniquement
votre smartphone n'est pas bon d'avoir
une clé donc votre smartphone fait
office de clé votre pixels pixels six
pixels syspro fait office de clé ça
c'est dispo uniquement sur les pixels
six pixels syspro la double appui c'est
disponible à partir du pixel 4 a donc ça
c'est hyper canon la fonctionnaire on
écoute céder le pixel 4 et puis les
détections d'action de voitures céder le
pixel 3a et ça ce sont des exclusivités
pixels donc regarder grosses exclues
pixels sur toutes ces fonctionnalités là
sauf la clé de voiture numérique qu'on
peut retrouver sur d'autres smartphones
et alors il ya une autre fonctionne et
et qui arrivait qu intéressante c'est la
fonction et de partage à proximité ça en
fait l'idée c'est pouvoir s'envoyer un
truc de l'un à l'autre a très facilement
à l'otan bouge pas je vais vouloir
envoyer une photo mais avant de te
l'envoyer jeu la faire et ben oui bouge
pas
ok j'ai la photo c'est moi
je te confirme ça c'est toi ça c'est toi
et là on est bien monté là on est bien
donc là je fais partager
je fais
je fais partage à proximité là il est
ouverte on voit là hop afro que cela on
est très à proximité voilà voilà pour
qu'un peu bouge pas reste par la tombe a
pas sa part toi tu le vois de l'autre
côté je vous téléphone doro
tu l'acceptent mais elle arrive et voilà
moi chez toi magnifique eu photo donc ça
c'est quand même extrêmement pratique
pour avoir effectivement un partage très
très proche et que ça parte directement
donc ça c'est cool il ya une autre
fonctionnalité qui est intéressant c'est
une critique arrive au mois de décembre
aussi également pixels syspro uniquement
attention ça il faut le savoir le
filtrage d'appels alors le filtrage
d'appels c'est assez intéressant parce
que lorsque quelqu'un essaye de vous
appeler il pas envie ça arrive souvent
des fois ouais et puis surtout s'ils
veulent vous vendre des formations n'en
peut plus on en soupe eh bien ça vous
permet de filtrer avant d'aller parler
aussi par exemple vous êtes en réunion
ou de matthias schepp a décroché mais je
peux quand même en converser à la
personne eh bien ça permettra à 2,2 de
parler à la personne directement par
écrit vous à savoir transcrire en fait
ce qu'elle vous dit et vous verrez si
vous allez prendre la pelle ou pas voilà
et on peut même choisir la voie ainsi
une voix féminine masculine un débat
alors bon
fait voir les voies mais
attention
c'est ok google j'ai reconnu c'est ok je
la connais ça
donc ça c'est cool donc le truc est très
pratique parce qu'effectivement ça vous
évite d'avoir à vous embêter d'être
toujours en train de se dire ok non ça
ça va être hyper relou je peux répondre
je ne réponds pas je filtre c'est pas
quelqu'un que je connais je suis pas sûr
je suis pas entraînement bt donc ça je
trouve ça quand même vachement bien
alors après ian holm autant parlé tout à
l'heure c'est le mode vision de nuit
dans snatch apte pour la alors on fait
si vous avez snapshot pouvait venir
activer le mode vision de nuit quand
vous avez moins de lumière ça permettra
d'optimiser vos photos pour avoir une
super qualité un capteur du pixel six
pros c'est pas un capteur vous passez
par semaine c'est vraiment le capteur de
téléphone qui a fait la vision de nuit
ça me chante et ça c'est vraiment top
parce que et c'est une exclu pixels sas
est sorti au mois de mars 2022 c'est un
pixel six pixels syspro sur les deux
pixels ça marche et c'est hyper canon
lauriane un truc qui est pas mal que tu
l'avais installé c'est le widget de la
batterie alors c'est un truc tout bête
mais c'est une fonctionnalité qui
arrivait au mois de mars également qu'on
peut avoir des lepic cesse d le pixel 3a
et ça vous permet d'afficher et bien
votre niveau de batterie de votre
smartphone mais également de vos bolt je
te laisse le met bien nos sens
mais également de vos buzz donc ça c'est
une cool et ça permet effectivement et
bien d'avoir ces petites informations là
vous voyez c'est un truc qui peut
paraître tout belle quand on en parle
comme ça mais ça n'existait pas avant et
c'est arrivé là donc ça je trouve ça
hyper canon et puis il ya un autre truc
qui est aussi intéressant une autre
fonctionnalité qui est arrivée celle là
au mois de mars également donc c'est
très récent uniquement pixels six pixels
syspro pour au moins 6 mois pourra
déployer après sur d'autres smartphones
android mais pour au moins six mois et
bien c'est des sous titres instantanée
pendant les appels quelqu'un qui a du
mal à entendre un appel qui a des
problèmes d'audition mais pourquoi pas
il peut directement à voir le sous titre
s'il arrive pas tous tenteront de
meilleur gardien français écoutent
terrorisme haut parleurs et tout est
affiché ça me fait une transcription en
même temps c'est ça et c'est vraiment
top ça va comme ça et le téléphone il
vraiment adapté à tout le monde et tous
les tous les mêmes personnes c'est que
vous êtes très inclusif et ses pratiques
parce qu'effectivement c'est là pour
tout le monde donc voilà pour ces
nouvelles fonctionnalités ce qu'on
appellera les feature d'europe qui sont
arrivés voyez tous les 3 mois elles sont
déployées alors là on vous a montré ce
qu'on avait tout de suite à notre
connaissance mais il y en a d'autres qui
vont arriver donc mars avril mai juin ça
va arriver soyez rassurés donc une
nouvelle fois ce n'était donc ça que je
trouve vraiment intéressant que ce
smartphone si vous voulez c'est que au
delà du copté pur google avec toutes les
fonctionnalités de base qu'on a au delà
du côté smartphones pour venir faire de
la photo c'est un très beau photophone
au delà de la performance on a un
smartphone qui se réinvente parce qu'on
a de nouvelles fonctionnalités régulière
et ça c'est cool tous les trois mois il
ya une petite news en téléphone vous
aurez de redécouvrir un petit peu tous
les trois mois et c'est super sympa mais
trois mois vous avez un cadeau qui
arrive à la maison c'est la dalle et
s'avoue également des femmes s'est calé
aux surprises pas habsheim chez toi
cadeaux merci beaucoup alors puisqu'on
parle de google ont tantôt c'est sa
transition 1 on se parle de google non
se parle également de sang les antilles
tout à l'heure ça c'est les google ce
sont les seuls épisodes a series
la monoculture et c'est ouais en fait
c'est ça sent les petits bugs et ses
petits bugs ils sont au plein emploi
voilà ça y est tu vois hop voilà c'est
bon on a à peu près c'est les pixels
butt a series à regarder sur faire la
même chose
on règle tous
voila c'est new york c'est hollywood on
voyage regarder et en fait alors ses
pixels buzz ah qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
venir faire alors on se dirait des bugs
ou qu'il y en a des tonnes et des tonnes
ce qui est intéressant effectivement
c'est la compatibilité c'est
l'écosystème et voyez aujourd'hui les
marques le savent les marques le
comprennent un écosystème c'est
extrêmement riche vous rentrez par un
smartphone et après vous allez prendre
d'autres trucs alors comme on est chez
google on va imaginer avoir un
chromebook on va imaginer avoir d'une
est à la maison pour la sécurité du nez
stub l'unesco mme nagle des enceintes il
y en a des tonnes et ce qui est cool
avec les pixels bugs à à combien tu
m'aimes 99,9999 ouais ça c'est la
meilleure fiac qui conduit c'est
barclays
hâle est balèze balèze est en fait c'est
l'idée c'est que vous avez l'assistant
dans vos oreilles donc il ya une vraie
complémentarité avec toutes les
fonctionnalités qui sont déployés sur
votre smartphone donc là on est
compatibilité à 100% et c'est ça qui est
aussi très intéressant c'est de son
écosystème elle est très riche et se
développe on va toutes les marques la
prennent à bras le corps parce que
soyons pas bête si google vous propose
un smartphone qui extrêmement petit
optimisé il serait quand même content
que vous ayez les buzz avec et puis pour
vous il ya un vrai sens parce que
l'expérience est complète et à moins de
100 mal ça fait tâche ouais ça fait
vraiment à flot produits qualitatifs la
batterie elle est top et franchement le
sont très très bien ouais tu peux tu
écoutes quoi toi en musique j'écoute la
musique c'est pas vrai ouais j'écoute la
musique ça plein d' historique c'est sûr
que tu écoutes jamais c'est pas toi qui
t'es dit y annoncer les cerveaux chez
musique music du tout c'est vrai ouais
j'ai d'autres passions mais ça c'est pas
écouter des podcasts
ouais je regarde des vidéos sur youtube
ouais toi je t'ai déjà vues sur youtube
par itunes dit quelque chose en ce jeudi
quelque part mais je sais pas vous allez
revenir je me suis dit c'est que j'ai
déjà vu
c'est sympa les bains ouais donc donc à
tous cette notion d'écosystème qui est
extrêmement importante et que je trouve
hyper canon donc
bien ces bugs n'oubliez pas eh bien
regardez oui regardez sous vos yeux
ébahis eh bien ils sont à gagner pour
gagner un pixel 6 et vos belles vous
avez la complète vous avez l'ensemble
pour participer c'est simple je voulais
me en eau du chat vous envoyer le code
pixels avec votre nom votre prénom à
l'iml qui est écrit c'est à dire jeu
avec un x jeu concours fnac tout attaché
on met pas de point pas de lien @ gmail
point com comme ça au moins vous êtes
peinard vous pouvez tenter votre chance
et puis si toutefois vous gagnez pas eh
bien vous avez du 27 mai jusqu'au 19
juin prochain sur la fnac 100 euros de
remise immédiate un média ouais c'est
immédiat je dire c'est pas un
remboursement dans deux ans immédiat sur
le pixel 6 ou le pixel syspro donc ça
c'est hyper hyper hyper hyper est hyper
canon ont refait un petit tour du côté
du chat on nous met le code ses pixels
oui vous en voyez j'ai participé le code
ses pixels je participe le code ses
pixels vous embêtez pas il ya rien de
bien compliqué que fixe ailleurs ouais
vous envoyer puis et puis mais taylor
une petite blague parce que si bien oui
j'aime bien les blagues parce que moi si
je bosse tu vois par exemple moi si mon
taf c'est d'aller notamment à son malade
regardez les emails et les traiter si je
vois des blagues de temps en temps ça me
fera marrer oui ça se trouve tanel la
gaieté votre blague qui fait que ça
passe ouais je pense pas à ça ça tisse
un tirage au sort on se regarde un petit
peu
c'est pas le concours de la meilleure
blague voilà les résultats du concours
c'est quand
j'ai pas les dates je saurais pas vous
dire mais vous avez l'email posez leur
la question lorsque vous envoyez vous le
saurez directement j'ai un petit message
de yagg halki mais j'aime pas les intra
ça rentre pas dans mes oreilles ça c'est
vrai que s'adapter aux rimes alors après
l'alternance et à différentes tailles
d'embouts peut-être n'as tu pas eu la
bonne taille d'embouts là dessus le côté
waterproof google est il fiable oui
parce qu'en fait ce sont des
certifications qu'on a tu vois les
pixels si ces pixels syspro son ip 68 ça
veut dire résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière donc ça veut dire que s'il
pleut s'ils tombent dans l'eau de
problème non il ya que des solutions
dans la poche arrière des fois vous
allez aux toilettes ça arrive je vais
déjà vu ne dit pas non je le sais
maintenant c'est déjà arrivé et pourquoi
pas de problème vous passez votre cadeau
et toi bien quoi exactement d'un petit
message aussi saluer monsieur greu salut
grâce à toi
acheté mon pixel 6 hier et ben coup tu
vois tant attendue de trois jours de
plus tu mets tu avais pas l'info taille
pas l'info mais ne soient pas déçus
c'est un super smartphone vraiment
éclatés incroyable ouais c'est ça
je vais peut-être enfin gagné pour une
fois je te le souhaite je vous le
souhaite à tous n'oubliez pas de
participer directement peut-être c'est
vous qui allez gagner
le package avec le pixel 6es avec vos
galaxie bugs ah ça c'est cool et
n'oubliez pas je vous le rappelle une
fois de plus avant de conclure la fin de
ce live 100 euros de remise immédiate
sur les pixels si ces pixels six pros du
27 mai au 19 juin prochain directement
chez la fnac
je vais bientôt va bientôt rendre
l'antenne mon ami j'avais un message à
passer à une statine tanda quelqu'un qui
te regardant sahara j'espère que tout le
monde va bien ouais ça lui mais surtout
au delà des produits vous avez une vraie
expérience google dans le téléphone ces
expériences qui est vraiment fait pour
tous les consommateurs on propose
quelque chose de vraiment simple
utilisable par tous le produit il est
beau le produit fait des photos
incroyables et vous souvenir ils n'en
seront que plus beau vous auriez plus
beaux souvenirs en plus on peut tricher
avec la gomme magique et plein de choses
à faire alors c'est mortel mortels
exactement exactement c'est mortel
mortel sur les belles paroles de jimmy
on va tous vous faire de gros bisous ça
fait quarante
sept minutes contre 48 minutes attention
le temps passe merci à vous d'avoir été
nombreuses nombreux on est combien tout
de suite la fête voir on est combien sur
mon attention parce qu'il ya aussi sur
le site de la fnac et aussi sur twitter
il ya un peu de tout les côtés un
milliard un milliard c'est ça le super
bowl a qu à bien se tenir au chaud là il
dit je vais arrêter là tu vas tu sais
quoi au revoir
le bon style de jeu reste très bon merci
à vous merci à tous
on continuera parler bien évidemment de
google parce qu'à des nouveautés qui
vont arriver et des annonces qui ont été
faites lors de la google ayo d'ailleurs
si vous voulez revoir un peu toutes ces
infos sur la google ayo j'ai fait une
vidéo dessus je vous invite à aller
jeter un petit coup de vous allez voir
c'est extrêmement intéressant et puis on
reparlera bien évidemment de google est
plein de jolies choses merci jimmy
d'avoir été à mes côtés c'est chouette
de faire ce live avec toi merci de m'en
reçu merci revient avec grand plaisir
merci la fnac et à google d'avoir été
partenaire de ce live je vous donne
rendez-vous bien évidemment très bientôt
sur youtube pour continuer à parler de
teck probablement de ces quatre sur le
site de la fnac allez savoir pour un
autre live ça pour être chouette en tout
cas prenez soin de vous amuser vous
profitez de la vie profiter de l'été et
puis on vous fait des très gros bisous
et surtout je vous dis à très bientôt
c'est le pont profitez-en tue pas rend
pontois ou pas non toi tu bosses tu sais
c'est cet avis est ton métier tu aimes
ça mais c'est ça non je sais je suis
femme voilà c'est là dessus qu'on
voulait ce bisou tiens
[Musique]